and it's a case that's gaining national
attention a young woman disappears while
she's on vacation in las vegas her name
rita fink bonner traveled here from
washington state last seen downtown area
now her family is really desperate for
any answers sasha loftus spoke with them
earlier tonight
we dismiss her a lot weeks after she
vanished in las vegas those who love
rita fink bonner are pleading for
answers we're very worried and concerned
the 30 year old traveled here from
washington state with her fiance and
friends
she was last seen at the bridger inn
hotel on september 3rd and every day she
doesn't come home is harder for her
family i just don't want her to think
we're not out there looking for her rifa
is a member of the lummi nation a tribal
community north of seattle
and according to the urban indian health
institute she's one of hundreds of
indigenous people missing across america
if you're indigenous if you're not
you know you you deserve to be found you
are a person
there's people that love you that's why
the people that know rita best are
speaking up to bring her home and help
others in similar situations i just hope
that
this helps more indigenous people reach
out
and say hey if they can do it we can do
it they hope their message will
encourage anyone who may know anything
to come forward so they can see her
smile again we just want her to come
home and be safe sasha loftus 8 news now